Ось так гатять ATACMS вже в Україні. Головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій Залужний
оприлюднив це відео зі словами подяки партнерам за підтримку.
Було завдано ударів по двох аеродромах в окупованих Росією Луганську й Бердянську
та знищено гелікоптери й іншу техніку росіян.
Дякую всім, хто воює й працює заради України! Дякую всім, хто допомагає!
І сьогодні особлива вдячність Сполученим Штатам.
Наші домовленості з президентом Байденом виконуються.
Виконуються дуже влучно - ATACMS себе показали. Слава Україні!
За даними американських ЗМІ, протягом останніх кількох днів США
відправили в Україну "невелику кількість" далекобійних ракет ATACMS.
Доставляли їх таємно через побоювання, що вантаж може бути атакований Росією
під час ввезення в країну. Крім того, Україна планувала застати росіян зненацька.
The New York Times, посилаючись на двох західних посадовців, стверджує,
що Україна отримала близько 20 ракет ATACMS.
Одна з умов надання - не використовувати їх для атак на територію Росії.
Також зазначається, що ракети ATACMS, надані українцям, мають касетний боєприпас,
який розкидає багато маленьких бомб, здатних завдати шкоди на великій території.
За оцінками Інституту вивчення війни, поява ATACMS в Україні призведе
до переміщення авіаційних засобів РФ далі від лінії фронту і, швидше за все,
суттєв ускладнить підтримку російською авіацією оборонних зусиль
і локальних наступальних операцій.
Особливо російськими гелікоптерами, які тривалий час були активними поблизу фронту,
щоб послабити наступаючі механізовані сили України, передусім на початку
контрнаступу ЗСУ в червні та липні.
Поява ракет великої дальності також становить значну загрозу
для російських складів боєприпасів у тилових районах і, ймовірно, змусить
російське командування обирати між укріпленням існуючих складів і подальшим
розосередженням складів по всій території окупованої України.
А перебазування російських літаків на аеродроми, розташовані подалі в тилу,
ймовірно, створить для Повітряно-космічних сил Росії значні проблеми
з координацією і підтримкою операцій.
Ракети ATACMS є різних модифікацій. Зокрема, дальністю польоту на 160 кілометрів
та на 300. Україна отримала поки перший варіант.
Ракета може бути оснащена як однією боєголовкою на чверть тонни,
так і касетними боєприпасами. ATACMS - це ракети класу "земля-земля".
Для пусків використовуються реактивні установки M270 MLRS або HIMARS.
Їх Україна вже має на озброєнні для ураження російських військ. ATACMS - балістичні ракети.
Вони здіймаються вгору і потім влучають у ціль майже вертикально.
Швидкість падіння ATACMS - понад 3500 км/год.
За словами речника повітряних сил Юрія Ігната, ці ракети дозволять знищувати
російські ракетні комплекси, які обстрілюють Україну з Криму.
Зокрема, комплекс "Бастіон", який випускає ракети "Онікс".
Саме цими ракетами росіяни атакували портову інфраструктуру на півдні України,
щоб завадити експортувати зерно.
Україна вже використовує британські далекобійні ракети Storm Shadow
та їхній французький аналог. Утім, вони не балістичні, а крилаті
і мають меншу швидкість. Крім того, це ракети класу "повітря-земля".
Їх запускають з літаків, які не можуть підлітати близько до лінії зіткнення
через російське ППО. А наявність далекобійних ракет ATACMS класу "земля-земля"
значно збільшує маневреність ЗСУ і непередбачуваність атак.
Пускові установки можуть непомітно приїхати на точку запуску,
відстрілятися й одразу від'їхати. Така непомітність дозволить запускати ATACMS
ближче до лінії фронту. Тож це дозволить Україні досягати майже всіх основних баз,
які Росія використовує на окупованій території для повітряної підтримки
і постачання своїх військ в Україні.
Крім того, на думку оглядачів, надання американцями далекобійних ракет ATACMS
має вплинути на Німеччину. Канцлер країни Олаф Шольц досі вагається
і не дає дозволу на поставки в Україну німецьких далекобійних ракет Taurus.
Зважаючи на новини про ATACMS в Україні, і німецька опозиція,
і члени правлячої коаліції посилять тиск на Шольца.
Ми як Європейський Союз повинні ще сильніше об’єднатися
з нашими трансатлантичними партнерами в НАТО, в ЄС, і, на мою думку,
зараз ми повинні бути ще більш рішучими в нашій допомозі Україні.
Путін буде дуже радий тому, що відбувається на Близькому Сході, тому що він вважає,
що це відволікає увагу від України.
Ми, хто підтримує Україну, відповідаємо на це чітко: ні, це не так.
Путін вже відреагував на передачу Україні далекобійних ракет ATACMS
і назвав це рішення "помилкою" США. Президент РФ також переконаний,
що це кардинально не в змозі змінити ситуацію на лінії зіткнення.
Втім, на думку оглядачів та експертів, сам факт надання ракет АTACMS
- важливий психологічний фактор як для українських військових,
так і для російських військ. Також це сигнал Кремлю, що Вашингтон й надалі буде
підтримувати Україну попри ескалацію на Близькому Сході та посилення суперечок
між демократами і республіканцями напередодні виборів у США.